اربع سنوات على وفاتها وجثتها لم تتحلل
وهو ما دفع المئات من الزوار الى التوفد
على بلده جاور الصغيره في ولايه ميزون
الامريكيه لرؤيه جثمان راهبه تدعى والهر
التي توفيت بعمر خمسه وتسعين عاما فبعد
وفاتها في التاسع والعشرين من مايو عام
2019 تم استخراج جثه الراهبه في ابريل
2023 بهدف اضافه ضريح شخص اخر ولد استخراج
جثمانها الراهبات كنا يتوقعن رؤيه عظام
فقط لكنهن تفاجا برؤيه جسدها بحاله شبه
طبيعيه خصوصا انها دفنت في نعشا خشبي بسيط
دون اي طحني تقارير اوضحت ان نعش لنكسر
تصدى وتسربت الرطوبه داخله مع ذلك ما زال
جثمانها بحاله جيده هذه الحادثه اثارت
تساؤلات عده ففيما يقول رجال دين ان الامر
له علاقه بالقداسه يرى خبراء ان التوابيت
والملابس قد تحمي الجث امين من التحلل